In 1996,
the FBI apprehensive man,
this alluded camp chef for nearly two decades,
is homemade letter bombs struck fear across the United States,
mostly targeting our lines and universities earning him the nickname the unit
Baalbek all told he killed three people and injured 23 more,
who took great care not to leave a trace of evidence,
and unlike other serial murderers,
he didn't seek glory and fame phase cuttings if it wasn't for his manifesto.
The publication that outlined his disdain of technology and modern society,
he may never have been caught after his arrest.
The world was shocked that this backwoods,
living hermits,
living without electricity or running water,
could be the man responsible for such sophisticated killings.
Today we explore this man,
the domestic terrorists and lone wolf killer Ted Kaczynski.
On May the 22nd 1942,
Theodore John [inaudible] was born in Chicago to blue collar,
second generation Polish Americans Theodore Tuck and one deck is inscape.
Seven years later,
the Kazinski had a second son who was called.
David's little is written about Ted's early years,
except for one incidents that may have been the impetus to the boy's tendency to
alienate himself according to his mother and brother.
When ted was a nine month old baby,
he developed a severe case of hives that required him to be quarantined for 10
days in the hospital afterwards.
Wonder reported it took a long time for her son to return to his normal,
happy self,
worried about his shyness and social development.
Once a claim,
she considered putting her young son into studies for autistic children,
but ultimately decided against it.
One neighbor remembered him as strictly a loner.
When Ted was 10 years old,
the penske family moved out of Chicago to the southwest suburb of Evergreen
Park.
At the time,
this was a neighborhood predominantly made up of Irish people,
Italians,
Czechs,
and pols to Ed's parents would later say that the move out of Chicago was so
that the boys could enjoy a better class of friends at Evergreen Park to thrived
and seems like a normal kid to most people,
except for one exception is remarkable intellect.
In the fifth grade,
ted was labeled a genius after he scored 167 on an Iq test is high marks,
puts him in the same Iq ranges,
theoretical physicist,
Stephen Hawking and Albert Einstein dead,
skipped sixth grades,
and then at the urging of school administrators his junior year of high school
as well.
Ted would later claim that his parents pushed him too hard and it's being
younger and smaller than his classmates,
made it difficult for him to fit in with his peers still.
He had made some friends and he was the ringleader of an outclassed clique known
as the briefcase boys that have a green park community.
High School Dad was especially adept in mathematics and science and spend hours
working out advanced problems.
In high school.
He joined the chest biology,
German,
and mathematics clubs.
He played trombone in the marching band,
explored the music of Bach and Vivaldi and Roche compositions for himself.
His younger brother,
David and their father to perform at home.
His physics teacher,
Robert [inaudible],
described him as honest,
ethical and sociable Ted attended summer school and was able to graduate at the
age of just 15 that year and he was wanting to five national merit finalists at
his high school.
One former classmates said Ted was never really seen as a person,
as an individual personality.
He was always regarded as a walking brain,
so to speak.
Ted seemed aware of how others viewed him.
He'd I just says,
by the time I left high school,
I was definitely regarded as a freak by a large segment of the student body and
he felt a gradual increasing amounts of hostility from the other children.
In 1958,
Ted was accepted into Harvard and just part of the recommendation letter,
his high school counselor then lower skill and wrote,
I believe,
Tad's as one of the greatest contributions to make to society.
He is reflective,
sensitive,
and deeply conscious of his responsibilities to society.
His only drawback is a tendency to be rather quiet in his original meetings with
people,
but most adults on our staff and as many people in the community who are mature
find him easy to talk to you and very challenging intellectually.
He has a number of friends among high school students and it seems to influence
them to think more seriously during this period of his life,
Ted held immense promise for his future,
but he may not have been ready to leave home.
One friend remembers urgent because Zinski's father not to let the boy go
arguing he's too young,
too immature,
and Harvard too impersonal
as an incoming Harvard freshmen because inscape was 16 years old that will
service Dr who interviewed him as part of the routine screening process.
Notice good impression,
created attractive,
mature for her age,
relaxed talks easily,
fluently,
and pleasantly likes people then gets on well with them.
Being among the youngest and brightest freshmen,
Ted's was housed at eight Prescott Street,
a three story Victorian House just outside of Harvard Yard.
That year,
the dean of freshmen,
Skiddy von stabbed junior,
decided to use the residents specifically for less mature boys who needed a more
intimate nurturing environments.
It was a place where those boys would not get lost in the larger impersonal
dorms,
so I've come to the conclusion that while the Dean's plan was well intentions,
putting all the fragile young men together had the opposite effect.
It isolated them making,
adjusting to Harvard even more difficult.
One student living at a Prescott later said it was not unusual to spend all
one's time in one's room and then rush out the door to library or class off to
his arrest because Zinski's housemates,
Gerald Burns,
wrote this.
He was as normal as I am now.
It was just hard on him because he was much younger than his classmates.
Despite the adversity,
he took up swimming,
wrestling,
played trombone,
and pick up basketball.
He also had a few friends.
Kaczynski is sophomore year,
marked the beginning of,
in his words,
the worst experience of my life together with 21 undergraduate students.
Kosinski was a participant in an unethical study conducted by Henry,
a Murray.
The Harvard professor and psychologist best known for pioneering personality
tests before Harvard,
Maria had been a colonel in theU ,
s army,
and an agent for the Office of Strategic Services Oss,
which later became known as the CIA.
According to his colleagues at oss,
Larry was obsessed with mind control and used lsd among other drugs to determine
how to brainwash subjects.
There is no evidence to suggest Marie used Lsd in his experiments with
Kaczynski.
Though the study was efficiently named multiform.
Assessments of personality development among gifted college men and its purpose
was to measure how the students reacted on distress.
Subjects were told that they would be debating personal philosophies with other
students and writing essays,
detailing their beliefs and their aspirations.
The essays were then sends over to anonymous attorneys who conducted vehement,
sweeping,
and personally abusive interrogations.
The participants want electrodes to monitor their physiological responses and
these sessions will also films later subjects.
Expressions of rage during the interrogations were repeatedly played back to
them.
Some sources have suggested that Mary study was part of the federal government's
research on mind control known as projects and gay ultra author Alton Chase.
Questions,
whether they purposely brutalizing psychological experiments contributed to the
making of Kaczynski the unibomber.
However,
by no means can Kaczynski is bombing campaign be laid at Harvard store,
though his staunch anti technological views are recognized in part to Harvard's
curriculum in the late 19 fifties,
Kaczynski and a bachelor of arts from Harvard in 1962,
you finishing with a three point one,
two GPA in his own words,
ted later records his experience overall this Harvard as a tremendous thing for
me.
He thrived on the hard work and self discipline and it became enthusiastic about
willpower.
Kaczynski enrolled at the University of Michigan in 1962 at the age of 20 and
spent the next five years of his life in Ann Arbor.
He earned his master's degree in 1964 and his doctoral degree in 1967,
Michigan.
It was not his first choice school.
He would have preferred the University of California at Berkeley or the
University of Chicago.
He was accepted to all three,
but Michigan offered Kaczynski a teaching position and a financial aid package
that Michigan had received $2,310 annually.
Roughly the equivalent of about $19,000 today during this time that you
specialized in geometric function theory and it's completed his dissertation
boundary functions to great claim.
His doctoral advisor,
Alan Shields,
called it the best I've ever directed.
Winning the Sumner Byron mires prize for Michigan's Best Mathematics
dissertation of the year.
Kaczynski published five journal articles based on this too.
While Michigan in three offset,
despite Kaczynski is academic success,
he ends 12 days and five days over 18 courses and his students rating him as an
above average instructs you did not enjoy Michigan.
He felt the standards were richards and the professors were mostly sloppy,
careless and poorly organized,
as he said,
most instructors and most students did only what they have to do.
There was no interest or enthusiasm or even any sense of responsibility about
doing a good job.
The mathematics department was enthusiastic about him,
but many others didn't seem to notice him.
Underneath the quiet and studious demeanor,
no one suspected his rage was building his ideology forming and it was at this
point that he apparently made the decision to start killing because sinskey
later says,
I thought I will kill,
but I will make at least some effort to avoid detection so that I can kill
again.
According to Sally Johnson,
who conducted a psychological profile on Kaczynski during his court proceedings,
it was during his fourth year at Michigan that he began to fantasize about
breaking away from society.
She wrote,
he decided that he would do whatever he always wanted to do to go to Canada to
take off in the woods with a rifle and try to live off the country.
If it doesn't work,
and if I can get back to civilization before I starve,
then I will come back here and to kill someone I hate.
Kaczynski.
Also shared with Johnson that he suffered from nightmares and sexual repression.
During this time,
he began fantasizing about being female and reasons the only way he would ever
be able to touch a woman was simply to become one.
Kaczynski went so far as even to go to the university's health center to discuss
a possible sex change,
but he had a sudden change of heart in the waiting room.
He shared with Johnson his feelings of humiliation ends of disgust,
and then suddenly felt better when he thought about murdering the psychiatrist.
Just then there came a major turning point in his life.
He later told Johnson like a phoenix.
I burst from the ashes of my despair to a glorious new hope.
In late 1967,
Kaczynski became the youngest assistant professor of mathematics in the history
of UC Berkeley.
He was 25 years old.
He stayed on for less than two years,
teaching undergraduate classes in geometry and calculus before a sudden and
unexpected resignation.
No one knew at the time that Kosinski never intended to launch his career at
Berkeley.
He only wanted to earn enough money to fulfill this plan of checking out of the
modern world is moving into the wilderness.
By the mid to late 19 sixties,
Kazinski had concluded that mathematics was too close to the evils of technology
which he despised.
In 1971 Kaczynski wrote an essay and it began.
It is argued that continued scientific and technical progress will inevitably
result in the extinction of individual liberty.
It was imperative that this juggernaut to be stopped,
Kaczynski went on.
This could not be done by simply popular,
rising a certain libertarian philosophy unless that philosophy is accompanied by
a program of concrete action.
Mm
often leaving Berkeley.
Kaczynski lived with his parents for two years before building his remote cabin
outside of Lincoln,
Montana on lands that he purchased with his brothers help.
The cabin was a simple structure with no electricity or running water.
At first,
he survived to working odd jobs using an old bicycle to get to and from the
town.
He tells himself survival skills such as tracking game and edible plants
identification as well as organic farming.
He visited the library and read classic works in that original languages.
In 1975,
he started to see the impacts real estate developments on the Montana wilderness
and it enraged him.
He had considered living peacefully,
but now all he wanted was to get back at the system by acts of revenge and carry
out his earlier fantasies of killing
from 1978 and 1995.
Kaczynski mailed or hand delivered a series of homemade bombs of increasing
sophistication.
He took great care not to leave any fingerprints behind it.
Purposefully left misleading clues to confuse the authorities as first bomb was
meant for Buckley.
Chris stay professor of materials engineering at northwestern university.
Chris was suspicious of the package and cooled campus police officer Terry.
Maker opened debts and it's the package exploders injuring makers lefthand,
a second bomb in May of 1979.
Were sent again to northwestern this time.
Mitch was a graduate student,
John Harris,
who suffered minor cuts and burns when it exploded because in this case,
next one was intended to blow up a Boeing seven to seven American Airlines
flight for four for traveling from Chicago to Washington DC.
The bomb was placed in the cargo hold and thankfully a faulty timing mechanism
prevented it from igniting.
It did really smoke,
forcing an emergency landing,
and author already stated that it would have had enough power to obliterate the
plane,
hadn't exploded.
There was at this point that the FBI opens the unabomber case and led a task
force made up of the Bureau of Alcohol,
Tobacco,
firearms,
and explosives,
and to us postal inspection.
Service analysis on the bomb materials proved fruitless because Zinski's
handmade explosives were made with scrap materials found almost anywhere for
more bombs caused unsuspecting victims,
Burns and cuts from 1980 to 1985.
The first serious injury that occurred on May the 15th,
1985 at Berkeley when graduate students and to captain in the U.
S air force.
John Houser opens the package.
He lost four fingers and vision in one of his eyes.
This bomb was followed by two more bombs in 1985 and then on December the 11th
of that year,
the blast from a Netherland splinter loaded bomb killed Sacramento computer
store and a huge.
And if this was the first of three unibomber casualties,
because Zinsky targeted another computer store owner Gary wrote in 1997 who
suffered nerve damage when the bomb went off after nearly a decade,
the FBI who was nowhere close to capturing the unibody,
but then all of a sudden he stopped sending bombs for a period of six years from
1987 to 1993.
The authorities simply thought he was gone.
They surmised he died my accidental death or natural causes,
or maybe had a change of heart because in reign of terror it wasn't over.
Though he mailed for more bombs from 1993 and 1995,
murdering two more people,
including Thomas Jane,
Masa and advertising executive.
And Gilbert's Brendan Murray,
a timber industry lobbyist is one of the bombs severely wounded and disfigured.
David [inaudible],
a computer science professor at Yale University and Charles Epstein and a
geneticist at the University of California San Francisco.
Kaczynski is bombs were often stamps with the letters fc and the FBI noted the
theme of nature and trees since the often included bits of bark and brunches.
His explosive packages
in 1995 because insignia contacted the media blackmailing the New York Times and
Washington Post into publishing his 35,000 word essay industrial society and his
future,
the media dubbed this the unabomber manifesto and in exchange for its release
word for word,
he would desist from terrorism and his manifesto,
Kaczynski asserts that the downfall of the human race can be attributed to the
industrial revolution and modern technological society.
Your claims,
widespread psychological suffering has taken place because of technologies
destabilizing effects and he argues people spend too much time engaged in
useless pursuits such as the consumption of entertainment,
our society.
It tends to regards as a sickness any mode of thought or behavior that is
inconvenient for the system.
And this is plausible because when an individual can't fit into the system,
it causes pain to the individual as well as problems for the system.
That's the manipulation of an individual to adjust to the system is seen as a
cure for a sickness and therefore as good Kosinski saw,
the only way of returning to wild nature and freedom was to destroy progress,
which he believed was entirely possible.
The manifestos reception was regarded as a work of genius by some and didn't
totally sane by others.
It has been compared to Aldous Huxley's brave new worlds and George Orwell's
1984.
James q Wilson wrote that it was a Catholic reasoned,
artfully written paper,
if it is the work of a madman than the writings of many political philosophers,
Zachary.
So Tom Paine called marks.
I'll scarcely more sane
following the publication of the manifesto.
David Kaczynski and his wife Linda noticed chilling familiarities between his
brother's letters and an earlier essay that Ted wrote for three weeks.
They pulled over years of correspondence looking for towel towel clues before
contacting the authorities.
Once convinced the unabomber,
it could be David's brother,
they hired an attorney,
contacted a criminal profiler to analyze the letters and contact the FBI.
At the time,
agents were actively following up on every 2000 tips and a recluse living in the
backwoods of Montana didn't seem to match their expectations,
not expert linguists analyze the letters and the essay and determined that they
were certainly the same man.
FBI agents arrested because then scale in April the third,
19,
96.
It is Kevin where he was found in an unkempt state,
etc. This cabin reveal to cache of bombing components.
40,000 handwritten journal pages that included bomb making experiments,
descriptions of the unibomber crimes,
and one live bomb ready for the mailing.
They also found what appeared to be the original type two manuscripts of
industrial society and its future.
By this point,
the unibomber had been targeted and for the most expensive investigation in fbi
history,
a federal grand jury indicted kaczynski in april of 1996 on 10 counts of
illegally transporting,
mailing and using bombs and three counts of murder because zinski's defense had
attempted to the insanity defense in order to avoid the death penalty that
kosinski refused.
He tried to fire as attorneys and attempted suicide by hanging on january the
ninth.
On the judge's order,
kaczynski underwent a psychological evaluation by sally johnson,
who gave him a provisional diagnosis of paranoid schizophrenia.
Regardless,
he was determined to be fit to stand trial and instead pled guilty on all
charges on january the 22nd 1998 in exchange for avoiding the death penalty at
the sentencing because ski displayed no emotion or remorse for his heinous
crimes.
The contents of his cabin were sold at auction and netted $232,000 because
zinski's victims today,
ted kaczynski is serving eight consecutive life sentences in a maximum security
prison in florence,
Colorado,
where he spends 23 hours a day in his cell.
He maintains an orally active connections with many people on the outside
through letters and contacted the media with regularity.
The lauder collection correspondence since his arrest with over Four hundred
people is housed at the university of michigan's special collecTions library.
Further,
his Montana cabin seized by the us government is currently on display at the
newseum in Washington dc.
So I really Hope you enjoyed them.
Biographics video.
If you did,
don't forget to subscribe to this channel for brand new biographies every monday
and thursday.
Also,
I've got another channel.
It's called top tens on that channel,
as you might've guessed from the name of it.
We look at all sorts of interesting top 10 lists.
You can check it out through the link on the screen now,
but if you're looking for something else to watch right now,
why not check out a biography from the archives or indeed a top tendons video
over there on the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.